get a grip of yourself man come take up
yoga you'll find it beneficial man
members will always find the chair a
friend if they wish to question a
minister but it ought yes they will and
with world oil prices falling and
revenues from the North Sea forecast by
the obr today to be down ninety-four
percent we would have seen catastrophic
cuts in Scottish public services
thankfully Scott Lurie mains a strong
part of a stronger United Kingdom
now mr. speaker the right honourable
member and former home secretary the
member for Hull west and hessle has
personally asked me to support his
city's year of culture and i am happy to
do so with the grant his campaign has
contributed to the arts while his
frontbench contributes to comedy both
sides are still shouting their heads off
it's very down market it's very
low-grade is very widely deprecated by
the public how it is that people think
that it's legitimate to behave in that
way and try to reconnect with the
electorate disillusioned with politics
is just bizarre and if some people are
so unintelligent they still can't grasp
the point I pity them John McDonald and
as my honourable member for wakefield
said this morning if hot air built homes
then conservative ministers would have
have sold our housing crisis over the
last year the chance has forced himself
on to building sites all around the
country to secure a photo with a hi-vis
jacket when the Chancellor Ginny is Bob
the Builder speech a Tory Party
conference what he didn't tell Doggett's
was that his abysmal investment record
to assist call made Osborne his dealings
with his newfound comrades I brought him
a long mouths little red book
gave me in front of mr. scooper
older I want to hear about the contents
of the book let's think you're fine and
then you'll find this invaluable but we
must not to pretend to know what we do
not know I thought it would come in
handy for him in his new relationship